[Musique]
henri-françois de breteuil merci d'être
venu sur ce plateau pour jour bonjour
merci de participer à ce v y paie vous
avez quitté votre château de choisel
quelques instants château intimement
liée à votre parcours personnel et c'est
vous qui avez décidé dès 1969 de
l'ouvrir au public
cela fait donc 50 ans on va parler de
tout cela ensemble pourquoi vous avez
fait ce choix dès le début dès 1969 de
l'ouvrir au public il y avait une
volonté de partager puis une volonté
aussi de faire rentrer aussi un peu
d'argent pour l'entretenir
cet établissement oui je crois que le
partage des essentiels parce que j'ai
toujours été attaché je dirai au public
tout simplement à faire connaître le
château recevoir aussi les
encouragements du public qui vient
maintenant nombreux au tout début
breteuil était dans les balbutiements
puisque nous avons reçu le premier jour
d'ouverture le 12 avril 1969 12
visiteurs donc ce record est largement
battu maintenant le visiteur annuel à
peu près 120 mille visiteurs annuels
donc louer vauvert pour cette raison là
je crois que quand on a un château il ya
deux solutions ou en se faire maigrir
soi même on les ouvre à tout le monde et
je voulais ouvrir et en plus l'ouvrir
tous les jours toute l'année sans
exception ce qui je crois est assez rare
même versailles et fermer un jour par
semaine
et puis la raison économique vous avez
mentionné bien sûr existe c'est grâce
aux visiteurs que breteil est devenu un
château pour tous et qui donc ce sont
ces visiteurs qui sont en quelque sorte
des mécènes des petits mécènes qui nous
aide énormément car sans eux il n'y
aurait pas de travaux il n'y en ait pas
de d'extension il n'y aurait pas de
nouveautés depuis 1969 vous n'avez pas
fermer qu'une seule fois le château vous
avez été toujours présent alors je suis
présent au tout début j'avais ma
carrière d'avocat
il évoque international donc
j'avais deux métiers et mon épouse était
elle beaucoup sur place éventuellement
un bébé dans les bras
et puis l emmener les villes les
personnes qui venaient pour organiser un
groupe pour organiser l'enterrement les
mariages et les emmener très
courageusement dans les salons etc
mais moi j'étais présent le soir on
faisait le briefing de la journée
et puis tous les week-ends j'ai toujours
accueilli tous les visiteurs tous les
week-ends et tous les jours des vacances
scolaires
donc je suis très présent cela pour lier
finalement l'histoire ancienne du
château les ancêtres avec l'histoire
présente 12 avril 1969 premier jour
d'ouverture 12 avril 2019 cela fera donc
s 50 ans vous avez prévu tout une série
de rendez vous j'imagine alors nous
sommes
au début bien sûr des choses nous savons
d'ores et déjà qu'il y aura une
exposition qui sera présentée dans la
grande galerie sur le thème un petit peu
de lille bien sûr de l'évolution
chronologique tout ce qui s'appelle est
passé pendant 50 ans mais également un
petit film qui va être consacré à
breteil qui va durer à peu près 10 à 15
minutes qui est en train de se mettre
sur pied et puis on a prévu aussi une
une petite fête pas heureusement une
grande veine une petite fête
on n'est pas très mondain breton namur
les choses un peu un peu personnel un
peu familial et ce sera le 18 mai on va
essayer d'inviter tous ceux dont le
dessin en quelque sorte est liée au
château la preuve les artisans les
architectes nos amis journalistes
bien entendu comme vous qui nous ont
soutenu les ligues qui ont été là
revoilà une une fête de famille en
quelque sorte pour le 18 mai revenons
sur l'histoire justement de ce château
et puis votre histoire vous êtes mais le
5 décembre 1943 vous avez suivi des
études de droit à washington à paris
vous êtes titulaire du certificat
d'aptitude à la profession d'avocat vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure vous l'avez
exercer cette profession en parallèle de
cette activité de 2 du château et puis
en regardant votre parcours scolaire on
voit que vous avez été lauréat du
concours général des lycées des collèges
en histoire vous aviez déjà cet attrait
pour l'histoire
j'ai toujours adoré l'histoire et je me
souviens même quand j'étais tout jeune
il y avait à breteuil toute une série de
livres d'histoire même quand j'avais 7
ans 8 ans dès que j'arrivais il faut
dire que le château à l'époque était en
très mauvais état on en parlera
peut-être tout à l'heure tu es un peu à
l'abandon mais je me précipitais dans la
bibliothèque et jeu d'abord j'ai regardé
tous les passages c'est en bretagne
charité commence par soi même en quelque
sorte et puis après je regardais tout ce
qui était sûr qu'on trouvait sur les
rois de france et c'est donc j'ai
toujours adoré lise doré voir les
histoires dans les livres et on
apprendre le plus possible sur les
ancêtres
et puis sur les droits qu'ils avaient
servi également sur l'angleterre puisque
retail est liée également à l'entente
cordiale et l'angleterre
oui entente cordiale la sphère du
collier de la reine votre votre histoire
votre famille et le château est lié à
tous ces moments importants de
l'histoire de france
vous l'avez dit je suis d'une famille
qui a donné trois ministres bourbon dont
le ministre des finances sous louis xiv
voilà donc vous êtes intimement lié à
cette histoire de france juste une
petite aparté on va voir une photo c'est
celle de jacques chirac
vous nous aviez confié une fois vous
vous l'avez connu jacques chirac dans
cette vie d'étudiant je vais t'en parler
maintenant
bien sûr j'ai très bien connu jacques
chirac dois dire que j'étais son
étudiant puis son assistant ça se
passait dans les années 60
je crois que je suis entrain science
courant enfin 61 après un voyage désuni
et jacques chirac ed ce qu'on appelait
le maître de conférences nous étions une
vingtaine et tout de suite j'ai senti
chez cet homme
d'abord une grande empathie pour les
étudiants vraiment et s'occuper d'eux il
arrivait qu'il ne réunissent jusqu'à 2
heures du matin chez lui ou chez moi ou
à breteil et caetera et c'était un homme
qui était vraiment coran dire qu'il y
avait une manière de voir les choses
tout à fait à la fois personnel et
entend un terrain pd1 pédagogue
on peut dire extraordinaire dans le
domaine de les deux sujets les et les
siens l'économie politique et les
questions de politique et c'était une
période un peu charnière puisque c'était
la fin de la guerre d'algérie et c'était
aussi devoir intéressant de voir comment
il réagissait et comment les étudiants
réagissait à la future perd
j'avais la russie on le voit votre
histoire est liée à celle de l'histoire
de france jusqu'au plus haut plus haut
jusqu'à la présidence jusqu'aux des
années plus récentes pardon j'en reviens
sur l'ouverture de ce château je referme
cet aparté vous n'avez qu'une vingtaine
d'années quand vous allez vous engager
dans la défense de ce château qui était
depuis le xviie siècle au sein de votre
famille votre père lui voulait le vendre
il estimait que ce château était un
fardeau c'est avec votre mère que vous
vous êtes battus et vous êtes allés
jusqu'à rencontrer andré malraux pour
faire classer le parc en fait un ace qui
a permis de le faire capoter les ventes
votre père vous en a voulu
finalement pas du tout mon père avait
une vision très différente du château
d'abord il était né en 1892 il avait
vécu toute une époque faste dans ce
château
il y avait 35 domestique il y avait des
paris avait des des artisans de toutes
sortes etc
donc il a connu tout ça il a connu aussi
les mêmes tout jeune la visite des rois
d'angleterre
le séjour du prince de galles une au
fond pour lui à notre époque un château
ce défi chu ont ils été lui-même
compositeur de musique entre aurait rien
en faire pour lui de ce château il
disait souvent c'est un éléphant blanc
et il a voulu le vendre je dirais parce
que par altruisme
pendant ce disant il faut débarrasser
monfils et la famille de ce château
parce qu'ils vont pas y arriver et ils
vont pourrir leur vie ils auraient mais
j'arrive aux états unis
et moi j'aime aucune envie d'aller vivre
aux états unis j'étais attaché au
château depuis prêté d'ma ma première
visite conscience quand j'avais 5 6 ans
et que l'ancien cuisinier du château
m'avait reçu c'est un peu d'ailleurs
extraordinaire pour moi que la formation
château et les venues dans tout premier
de lucien tessier qui était le cuisinier
de mon grand père
non pas qu'il ait formé à la cuisine
mais il m'a formé à toute l'histoire qui
était lié à ce château parce que lui
avait connu tout le monde tous les gens
qui dessinaient dans ce château
alors mon père était donc sincère dans
sa volonté mais moi je n'étais pas du
tout d'accord il pensait que le touriste
n'existait pas pour lui on n'y
arriverait jamais c'était une
catastrophe et alors
finalement on a il a signé une promesse
de vente à des promoteurs abominable qui
voulait faire a noté de 400 chambres qui
voulait faire du tennis sur air et
surtout ce qui a terrorisé le village un
night club alors se déroulera le breton
va devenir un lieu de perdition
épouvantable alors sarkozy à faire peur
un peu aux gens et puis là dessus le
château était inscrit à l'inventaire on
est grâce à andré malraux nous sommes
allés voir avec ma mère il a été classé
dans tout son parc et du coup les pour
les promoteurs sont partis effaré ils
ont tout lâché ça fait pschitt et le
château n'a pas été vendu il ya encore
quelques temps se disent de location
mais finalement mon père l'a donné en 67
et on l'a ouvert en 69
aujourd'hui 120 mille visiteurs annuels
grâce notamment au choix que vous avez
fait en application de votre épouse
aussi autour ses choix autour d'eux à
des contes de perrault à ceux qui ont
visité le site le savent bien vous
et mis en scène ses contes de perrault
là aussi liée à vos ancêtres de la
famille oui parce que charles perrault a
travaillé pour un breton un an c'est le
ministre de louis xiv que vous venez de
mentionner louis de bouteilles et
charles perrault était le directeur du
trésor royal une sorte de on dit de nos
jours n'a il ya toujours un directeur du
trésor qui n'est plus royal et
républicains mais ça existe toujours et
charme perron était une sorte de
ministre de la culture ce qui s'est
occupé d'eux des tuileries s'est occupé
de versailles pour les travaux les
grands travaux et à la fin de sa vie
seulement il va écrire les célèbres
contes
il est âgé il a une petite fille qu'il
va dédier les célèbres contes de
perrault cendrillon la belle au bois
dormant
nous en avons 8 maintenant au château
beauté évoqué non en son et lumière avec
le concours de christophe leray qui est
un jeune scénographe de beaucoup de
talent vous avez une obligation de vous
renouveler en permanence pour ce château
pour continuer à attirer les visiteurs
et les faire revenir aux siens il faut
toujours se renouveler il faut des
nouveautés j'irai d'abord il le faut
pour eux pour faire plaisir à nos amis
journalistes parce que nos amis
journalistes ne parlerai pas de breteuil
si on leur disait chaque année portail
est ouvert aux visites tous les jours
toute l'année etc
il faut qu'il y ait des nouveautés donc
il faut chaque année où une nouveauté
dans le jardin où une voisine château
mulhouse voter dans les comptes ou
éventuellement les 3d seront à la fois
et c'est comme cela
comme vous le disiez que le public vous
êtes amené à revenir faire une
d'autres visites bourgou de personnes
bientôt château et reviennent c'est vrai
et ça devient beaucoup m'ont dit c'est
notre maison du week end le château
lorsqu on y vient on se promène heureux
à breteil a aucune pelouse interdite ou
quoi que ce soit on veut jouer au
football on peut faire tout ce qu'on
veut
les les personnes les visiteurs se sent
complètement chez eux et ça c'est très
je crois très original c'est pas jadot
classique
c'est un château de famille ou au fond
le visiteur pour moi presque
ils partagent avec nous le
l'agrément de l'avenue un demi-siècle
d'implication pour défendre ce château
est ce qu'à un moment vous pensez vous
vous dites aussi pour que ce château
reste dans la famille il faut que je
passe la main est ce que vous pensez à
cet avenir là aussi bonne question je
dirai que j'ai deux trois enfants deux
filles et un garçon a priori monfils est
le mieux formés parce qu'il est il
travaille dans l'un des finances de la
banque
je pense que il pourra bien sûr le
moment venu s'en occuper mais comme il
un job extrêmement non à paris il a
aucune envie pour le vent de le faire il
nous conseille un peu de temps en temps
il vient nous voir mais pour le moment
il n'ya il n'y a pas de passage demain
prévu parce que le le candidat éventuel
et n'est pas encore prêt parce qu'il a
il est une quarantaine d'années il a
toute sa vie
d'heureux de bureaux à réussir il était
le voisin de bureau de monsieur macro
nerfs pour une petite anecdote chez
rothschild dont ils travaillent donc ils
étaient face à face avec monsieur mâcon
il ya quelques années mais je crois que
le contact n'est pas
et sympathique mais enfin ils se sont un
peu perdus de vue macro a d'autres
choses à faire que occupés est il tabou
qu'est ce que vous êtes inquiet juste
pour l'avenir de ce château du coup
inquiet pour l'avenir du château
comme pour le moment là je crois que
château je ne suis pas inquiet pour
l'avenir du château
mais je pense que les choses
automatiquement se passe on d'une autre
manière joie quand il changera
propriétaire parce que je ne pense pas
que mon fils aura la possibilité de
faire ce que je veux ce que je fais à
dire des doors 360 deux jours sur trois
ans être présents château d'accueillir
lui-même les visiteurs etc
je pense qu'il le fera mais d'une autre
manière peut-être deux fois par semaine
je pense qu'il lâchera pas son job tout
de suite il dérobe pas ça pas une bonne
idée mais il est à il est un bon
économiste on qu'il choisira bien les
les travaux les axes et cetera mais moi
j'ai une formation assez culturel ce que
j'ai travaillé pour l'événement
historique long qu'à la caisse nationale
des monuments historiques j'ai prise il
admire historique
j'ai toujours été dans le milieu
voilà donc ça ça aide aussi pour
comprendre le monument et pour prévoir
son avenir ce qui me permettra de
conclure sur cette citation de votre
épouse que l'on retrouve sur le site
internet justement l'histoire des
maisons est très liée à celle des hommes
elle s'inscrit dans le temps et ne
s'arrête pas avec nous ce qui correspond
assez bien à ce que vous venez de nous
expliquer merci marie françois de
bretagne d'être venu sur ce plateau nous
allons refaire mais ce v y est et puis
nous reviendrons sur les 50 ans et les
différentes animations qui seront
prévues dans un prochain rendez vous du
7 8 culture sur notre antenne à très
bientôt
[Musique]